how you been brother good to see you hi
Jason hey Jim off your you're healed
from your spanking at poker last week oh
that was not fun that was not fun Jake
Alan tilt but there was some good wine
and it was good to have you back Jake al
is a melty little guy for the last 18
months while I was healing myself I was
not at the poker game he was running
over everybody verbally and I showed up
and for the first 15 minutes all I did
was literally tear everybody a new one
just randomly I mean just destroying
everything or - guy was destroyed
everybody was in a puddle and then Jake
I lost when Jake al loses he shuts up he
clams up really quiet I get very
frustrated with myself when I make bad
plays I don't get frustrated by
randomness I don't mind getting sucked
out on its I know when I did something
stupid try to get better but speaking
about doing stupid stuff hey how's the
last year been for you last year has
really I mean honestly it is facetious
but it's been a lot of changes it has
been the most incredible year of my life
yeah 18 the last 18 months has probably
been the most profound 18 months of my
life well let's get into it a bit I I
remember you were here a couple years
ago and obviously you've spoken our
events been on the pod a whole bunch of
times you're one of the highest rated
speakers we've ever had because you're
always very candid you're also very
ambitious and I watched social capital
go from being what I would call the
classic series a and seed stage fund and
then you added an IPO a and then you
added a growth fund and a hedge fund and
this grand vision started to emerge and
now it seems like you've deprecated all
that and gotten back to the roots what
happened why how did you wind up here um
well it was a lot it was a lot of me
just trying to figure out who I was as a
person and trying to just have
confidence in myself and not be so
completely insecure and a lot of my
success was always rooted in my this
massive inferiority complex that I had
not white not rich not well-educated
blah blah blah blah blah you know you
you pack on all this baggage over so
many years but it can be really
instrumental in motivating you and it
was very
motivating for me and so it worked for a
really long time but then I started to
fall for a lot of the trappings of what
some of that had given me meaning you
know when I was in the in sort of years
6 7 & 8 of social capital I frankly got
distracted I started out with this
mission of wanting to work on really
important companies and ideas and work
with founders for you know decades and I
thought that's what would be necessary
to really solve some important problems
in the world and so in order to do that
I thought well let me put in a lot of my
own money and then I'll establish
control and all of that was true but I
still fell for it next thing you know I
was flying around London Paris New York
Abu Dhabi Riyadh and you're meeting with
all these people that you think are
important and as with a lot of things
what happens in mythology is when you
get close to the myth it disintegrates
and you realize that there's really not
much there and that in often times the
emperor has no clothes I think about all
of the entrepreneurs you aspire to meet
that you think are exceptional I
probably know all of them you would
probably and I if we rated one to ten
would give them very different scores
because they're just normal people and
they have the same weaknesses and you
know faults and trappings that we all do
and so in any event the point is I got
to a place where I was like nothing is
working for me meaning I was richer than
I had ever been or more well-known or
more notoriety and I know thoroughly
unhappy and you've gotta be a team or a
piece of it a big piece of it the
Warriors that won multiple championships
and that was mind-blowing for both of us
to hang out at Warrior Games or take him
to Vegas yeah have fun and it was kind
of mind-blowing but at the end of the
day you kind of drifted away from what
you were good at I was I was not happy I
mean well at the core of it I was just
fundamentally not happy and so how does
it manifest it manifests in the
following ways one I was very
emotionally unavailable to my family I
was unemotional to my friends
unavailable I was basically absent
building a business that I didn't want
to be
building meaning constantly on the road
constantly on a plane beating up my body
beating up my mind and it took me in
these last 18 months the courage to just
say enough and basically what it was was
me seeking out my own therapy and all of
a sudden I realized there is so much
baggage that relates to the trauma that
I had when I was a kid and I had always
talked about it but I had never really
dealt with it you know and there's
something and I would just put a very
fine point on it which is a lot of us
deal with baggage and trauma as from a
childhood in my specific case what it
left was a deep gaping hole where I felt
completely unworthy and not whole boom
that's the end that's there's a lot of
stuff that comes up to it but that's the
takeaway that's the punchline immigrant
family alcoholic father abusive
psychologically and physically and all
of us have versions of all of this
trauma the point is that I felt zero
zero zero sense of Worth and so I chased
everybody else's definition of what
worthy and successful should mean and I
did a good [ __ ] job about it - yeah
you were faking a pretty good there for
a while I mean like you know I could
dunk with the best of them I mean truly
but it was not making me happy and it
took me into my early 40s to say what is
what is gonna change this this sort of
lingering burning sensation in my
stomach and so I just went off to fix
these things and so it caused a ton of
dramatic change both personally in my
life and professionally in my life and
professionally the most important thing
is I said I'm building somebody else's
company and I'm sure all of you guys
founders have felt that moment where
it's like am i building the thing that I
want or am i building the thing that
somebody else wants
well these investors will tell you
they'll give me money if you do this
this this and this some of it feels poor
some of it feels doesn't cool it doesn't
feel core well guess what happens when
somebody tells you tomorrow I'll give
you five billion dollars you just need
to do this this and this and I'm like I
don't need your five billion but then my
partner's like no we want theirs too and
yours and if you don't do it we will
quit or this and that and all of a
sudden it's like the business of being
in a business takes over and then you
forget what you were there for in the
first place
mission goes out the door values go out
the door the way in which you made
decisions go out the door your risk
tolerance changes again I think what I
went through a lot of founders go
through and there have to be these
moments where you basically circle the
wagons and say enough is enough
or you capitulate and that was my choice
I had to either capitulate or I had to
basically rip it all down and I chose to
rip it all down
[Music]